bonsoir daniel à steinbach merci d'être
avec nous 23 ans de métier cette
agricultrice qui jettent tout simplement
l'eponge ça paraît incroyable
que vous inspire cette histoire bien les
cette histoire on la connaît depuis
longtemps j'avais moi même porté leur
dossier lors d'une réunion qu'on avait
eu avec le secrétaire d'état sébastien
lecornu il ya deux ans ça m'inspire
d'abord une première chose c'est
incroyable que l'administration ne fasse
rien ça me dépasse et à la limite contre
premiers riffs pour eux ils pourraient
avoir l'intelligence de se pencher sur
le cas mais c'est sans doute parce que
le problème le plus général moi je
voudrais redire ce qu'on ne dit pas
assez c'est que les éoliennes ce sont
des machines industrielles gérante
ils font aujourd'hui jusqu'à 240 mètres
de haut 150 mètres d'envergure que l'on
installe dans les campagnes les zones
agricoles ou naturelles qui sont
normalement interdits de toute
construction
donc on installe de façon sauvage des
zones industrielles dans des zones qui
ne sont absolument pas prévu pour ça des
machines qui comporte un certain nombre
de nuisances
d'abord le bruit des lumières des
nuisances pour les oiseaux donc une vie
très très difficile pour tous les gens
qui habitent aux alentours et qui était
venu là pour la campagne ou qui vivent
de la campagne comme madame bouvet ce
sont des machines qui sont laissés
absolument sans surveillance sans
contrôle
elles sont télécommandés depuis un coin
isolé de france de montpellier lille
qu'on sait pas l'allemagne ou l'espagne
les éoliennes qui produisent de basse
fréquence est ce que c'est ça qui
pourrait avoir un impact sur la santé
des humains
peut-être et des animaux parce que c'est
vrai que le commun des mortels a du mal
à comprendre comment justement ces
éoliennes
avoir un impact aussi négatif comme on
vient de le voir dans ce reportage
eh bien d'abord ne serait-ce leçon
lui-même
bon il ya les infrasons mais il ya le
son lui même est lui-même de l'ordre de
103 105 décibels donc c'est une c'est un
bruit considérable
donc il est un peu à distance mais selon
les conditions de météo de transmission
etc
ils peuvent être excessivement bruyant
je vous il ya le cas des chauffours dans
l'orne où la préfète a décidé qu
effectivement il y avait trois oui il
fallait faire une enquête mais n'a
toujours pas signé l'arrêté qui permet
l'arrêt des éoliennes et commence l
enquête mais bon le bruit excessif des
éoliennes il est bien connu et des
connus par des dizaines de milliers de
français aujourd'hui ce qu'on a fait ce
qu'on a du mal à comprendre daniel
steinbach c'est de voir que ce phénomène
il vous est connue depuis très longtemps
et que le gouvernement n'a pas réagi les
ans les ministres concernés subissent
des plaintes aujourd'hui un la part de m
division l'état a commis une faute
volontaire parce qu'on imagine qu'ils
aient la conscience de ce danger tout de
même je ne sais pas s'il en a conscience
oui s'il en a conscience et bien ils
sont content que ne peut pas installer
des machines de 240 mètres des machines
industrielles de 240 mètres de haut et m
105 décibels de bruit dans des campagnes
sans protection sans rien dans des zones
naturelles et agricoles qui sont
normalement interdits dans la
construction parce qu'elles sont
protégés parce qu'on a voulu les
protéger c'est que la conséquence de ce
phénomène global on n'installe pas
impunément des dizaines de milliers de
machines industrielles géante dans la
campagne sans prendre aucune précaution
sans aucune surveillance avec des
surveillances par télécommunication et
des centres de conte des centres de
surveillance qui sont parfois en
allemagne en avaient eux aussi en avant
pour autant de liberté pourquoi autant
liberté pour les constructeurs
d'éoliennes c'est une façon de se donner
bonne conscience avec le grand projet de
transition et écologique
oui oui c'est purement idéologique ou
alors pompon pour certains pour madame
ton qui dit c'est certainement
idéologique pour d'autres c'est
peut-être plus bassement électorales
mais aujourd'hui ils pensent que c'est
une solution vendeuse chez voilà ils le
font ils s'intéressent pas aux
conséquences réelles
ah ah c'était vraiment le problème est
assez conséquent cela elle
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs ça tombe bien les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre ont
baissé de 1 7% en 2010 9,1 c'est ce qu'a
annoncé pierre le gouvernement est ce
que vous vous diriez aussi que c'est
plutôt à un succès de ce point de vue là
la transition écologique pour le moment
bien il ya très longtemps que la france
a baissé ses déchets ces émissions des
gaz à effet de serre au contraire il est
à craindre que depuis la fermeture de
fessenheim les conditions françaises se
sont un peu détériorée
les émissions du moins pour la
production d'électricité et alors et
puis compte tenu de la baisse d'activité
avec le co vite 1,6 pour cent de
diminution des émissions à gaz à effet
de serre pour 8 ou 9 % de diminution du
bébé c'est plutôt un mauvais résultat
s'il n'y a rien à dire il ya rien pour
le co2 d'ailleurs le préfet carenco
président de la cre eux devant la
commission parlementaire sur les
énergies renouvelables a déclaré qu'il
était complètement faux de voir dans les
énergies renouvelables
une solution pour diminuer les effets de
serre les gaz à effet de serre en france
s'adresse à figurent dans le rapport de
la commission robert de marcio blanc
quelle énergie devrions-nous privilégié
pour entamer cette transition écologique
selon vous ce sera ma dernière question
je ne sais pas le but de vent de colère
on est défenseur d'un verte sur l'éolien
on
pas la science infuse on n'est pas des
experts de l'énergie et puis il faut
laisser le temps au temps et il ya des
millions de chercheurs dans le monde qui
se penche sur la question
malheureusement je peux pas vous
répondre merci en tout cas de votre
franchise et de votre point de vue sur
cette question des éoliennes merci
daniel steinbach d'avoir été avec nous